[Música]
cuando la gente se entera que soy
youtuber siempre me hacen las mismas 3
preguntas la primera es conoces a juià y
sí sí la conozco la segunda es eres
millonario y no ojalá suscríbete a mi
canal este y la tercera es como le
hiciste y pues nada justo eso les vengo
a contestar hoy cuando era adolescente
mi mejor amiga era una niña que nació
con un síndrome o una enfermedad que
afectaba a sus articulaciones
por eso sus brazos y sus piernas eran
visualmente diferentes ella describía la
vida como si estuviera rodeada con un
plástico y como si no pudiera tocarlas y
fuera si a alguien externo y aunque esto
suene muy dramático la verdad es que yo
la entendía muy bien porque por mucho
tiempo yo me sentí exactamente igual yo
vi a la gente que a toda la gente a mi
alrededor tenía algo o eran muy guapos
son muy buenos en la escuela buenos en
los deportes y yo pues era yo
soy invisible e irrelevante la verdad es
que pensaba que las únicas personas que
me querían era mis papás y porque era
prácticamente esa obligación
este bueno claro evidentemente soy gay
por si no se habían dado cuenta hola y
este pero esto para mí en ese entonces
era el último de mis problemas o sea
este era más como la cereza en el pastel
era una cosa que dije sabes que esto ni
siquiera lo voy a pelar lo voy a dejar
así como al fondo y nunca voy a pensar
en esto y para mí la idea de encontrar
el amor o la felicidad de una manera
pues la de la manera tradicional que nos
venden en todos los medios pues yo lo
veía como algo imposible por esta época
también en la cultura pop era todo
acerca de las it girls parís
britney y mi favorita personal lynch y
por supuesto entonces no sean los que
sean de mi generación recuerdan que
todos los medios cubrían siempre la vida
de estas chicas o sea no había revista
que no hablara de la moda de las fiestas
de todo el estilo de vida de estas tres
mujeres y evidentemente para mí yo de 14
años esto era muchísimo más relevante e
importante que tener clase de 7 con mis
esperancita claro
entonces este pero mi amiga y yo siempre
veíamos estas revistas pensá imaginando
cómo sería hacer como ellas como las
personas de sus páginas también por esta
época mi abuela me regaló una película
de marilyn monroe y fue amor a primera
vista la verdad es que para mí marilyn
desde el primer momento que la vi a ella
representaba todo lo que yo no era era
era guapa era querida era la colorida
famosa y para mí se convirtió en un
simple silogismo después de todo esto si
yo quería ser feliz tenía que ser famoso
y si quería ser famoso tenía que ser
actor
ahora que voy a ser muy honesto con
ustedes para mí es muy vergonzoso estar
aquí parado admitiendo le permití
advirtiéndoles que me meta en la vida
era ser famoso pero si lo vemos desde
una perspectiva evolutiva la verdad es
que la aceptación en el grupo y el amor
son una de las necesidades más
inherentes a los seres humanos así que
he visto esta manera me parece una
aspiración válida y natural incluso digo
quitando el estigma pero bueno cuando
uno decide que su trabajo a futuro va a
ser ser una celebridad rápido te das
cuenta que no es un trabajo que puedas
buscar en el periódico pues necesitaba
un plan en la primera persona que pensé
fue en eddy vilard para los que no sepan
quién es y vive lard es un niño que en
esa época hacía muchos comerciales sino
es que todos el de la bula bueno no sé
si lo vieron pero hacía muchos
comerciales después hizo un papel en un
vídeo con belinda y eventualmente se
consiguió un personaje en esta novela
que era muy popular en esa época rebelde
entonces para mí fue muy sencillo dije
ok si quiero ser feliz tengo que hacer
muchos comerciales hacer un vídeo con
belinda
y conseguir un papel en rebelde claro
y entonces me metí a busca agencias en
internet y empezó a hacer castings como
loco iva o como a tres o cuatro al día
desde las tres de la tarde que salía a
la escuela hasta las diez de la noche
que era el último y bueno en los tiempos
muertos hacía mi tarea porque si lo
hacía
y en dos años de ir a casting
religiosamente hice cinco comerciales
cuatro de ellos como extra
rápidamente me di cuenta que yo no
estaba recortado para esta industria si
yo no me parezco a los hombres que salen
en la televisión o sea ahorita menos
pero en ese entonces tampoco pero en ese
entonces tampoco yo no me parecía los
hombres que salían en la televisión
entonces cuando uno piensa en marilyn
alguien así como marilyn o como elvis o
como frida son personas que se han
vuelto conceptos tan simplificados que
ya ni siquiera necesitan apellido todos
sabemos quiénes son pero la mayoría de
la gente no sabe de dónde vienen y les
voy a decir algo uno no pasa de ser una
niñita sin casa a uno de los iconos más
grandes del siglo 20 tienen medio haber
sido una persona muy peculiar entonces
la historia en la que marilyn se
convierte java el ser norma jeane
mortenson para convertirse en marilyn
monroe empezaba a sonar muy familiar
ahora en los 40 había una cosa que se
llamaba el star system y es cuando los
estudios agarraban a aspirantes actores
los pasaban por un proceso de relaciones
públicas y de este y de imagen y los
convertían en productos rentables se me
ocurrió que tal vez yo tenía que pasar
por una especie de star system y moldear
médica ver en este molde que era la
norma como los personajes o como los
hombres que yo verían la televisión más
masculino más musculoso y más europeo
como todos hemos visto a esa gente así
que va ahora la cirugía plástica
maquillaje dentista clases de baile
clases de actuación hice todo y les digo
algo
ha tenido más dinero hubiera hecho más y
aún así no fue suficiente
cuando madeleine cumplió 22 años estaba
más o menos igual que yo y estaba
divorciada desempleada y con una deuda
de 50 dólares sobre su auto ganando como
siempre
al poco tiempo conocí bayón y hyde que
éramos super buena gente
y le consiguió trabajo por los tres años
siguientes de hecho creo que los más
definitivos de tu carrera
hollywood se trata mucho de a quién
conoces pensé que si tal vez no podía yo
adaptarme el star-system entonces tenía
que conocer a alguien pero pues mi papá
es médico y mi mamá es contadora
claramente no conocía mucha gente
entonces se me ocurrió pensar en esta
teoría de los seis grados de separación
esta que dice que todos estamos a seis
personas de cualquier persona en el
mundo de hecho creo que tres era ahora
tres gracias a facebook
y dije tengo que conocer mucha gente y
rápido entonces se me ocurrió ser mesero
de ahí pasé a un bar de ahí pasé a una
tienda de ropa y luego telemárketing
hasta que por mi amigo jorge conocí a
david lachapelle el david lachapelle
fotógrafo de hollywood
y bueno para los que no conozcan el
trabajo de dividir aquí está con las
kardashians su trabajo habla mucho de la
fama y de ser transgresor él a su vez
fue discípulo de andy warhol podemos ver
la siguiente foto era a su vez fue
discípulo de andy warhol y éste que
hablábamos tenía este discurso en los
sesentas como de quince minutos de fama
y de ser transgresor y su musa era
mándale porque ese soy yo por cierto
para los que no me reconozcan con
cabello corto y su musa era mándale
porque es una mujer transexual que se
hizo famosa por literalmente adoptar el
estar el star-system y construirse pieza
por pieza
inspirado en quien más en marilyn monroe
yo no sé si ustedes crean en estas cosas
pero si alguna vez el universo intentó
dar un mensaje para mí éste estaba en
cartulina fosforescente y subrayado
doble era la primera vez que conocí a
una persona que había alcanzado el
concepto que yo tenía de éxito a pesar
de ser muy diferente a la normal
este es si después me acerqué a su
equipo de relaciones públicas de davín y
les pedí trabajo y aceptaron para mi
sorpresa y me convirtieron como en el
office boy digo nada glamoroso yo era
así de que llevaba el café y sacaba
copias y así o sea me decían de hecho
siempre me preguntaban si sabía hacer
algo y les decía que sí y luego lo bucle
ava y ya entonces si bien no me es no
vendo no lo estaba haciendo por el
dinero lo que estaba aprendiendo de
contactos y de relaciones públicas en
ese momento era invaluable al poco
tiempo me encontré trabajando en el área
de comunicación de mtv latinoamérica y
haciendo una pasantía para una revista
muy importante de moda de este país y si
bien no encontré la oportunidad que
estaba buscando a lyon y hyde que estaba
buscando lo que sí aprendí fueron dos
cosas la primera fue justo en esta
revista de moda un día que me puse mi
jefa me puso a elegir las fotos para un
artículo
y este ya está como que me aceptó todas
pero me rechazó una la dura modelo de
piel obscura y lg como por y me dices
que me dice es que tenemos órdenes de
arriba de no poner gente morena en las
publicaciones o que yo dije esto me dejó
pensando en mucho como los medios
influyen en la forma en que vemos el
mundo en este caso la belleza la forma
en que los gays son representados
usualmente los medios es la siguiente
podemos poner a tus tías
todos los conocen son personajes
ridículos excesivamente amanerados
tontos y cuya única motivación es
ligarse a todos los hombres a su
alrededor porque claro a los gays nos
gustan todos los hombres y ojalá así no
sería soltero pero bueno
es la segunda cosa que aprendí en esta
época de tantas fiestas y eventos fue
sobre el whisky y bueno ustedes saben
que el whisky ese turista la primera vez
que lo toman es una bebida que sabe a
plástico dices qué horror después la
segunda vez que la toma sobre temas un
poquito más y la entiendes
mira no está tan mal hasta que
eventualmente se convierte en un señor
jack daniel's un peso donde quiera que
esté
y si a lo que voy con esta analogía es
que los hábitos de consumo cambian tan
si cambian que ahora somos dependientes
de objetos que hace 15 años ni siquiera
existían podemos regresar tantito a las
fotos de tus tías clics
si yo veo a ver si yo veo es si yo soy
un ama de casa o un hombre de negocios
que se la pasa todo el día a la oficina
y me topo con esto en horarios del área
es mi única acercamiento al mundo gay
por supuesto que no quiero que los gays
adopten me quiero que tengan hijos y
esto no tiene que ver con ser femenino
tiene que ver con ser una broma y si
ustedes creen que es un estereotipo como
este no les afecta dice no yo no soy gay
a mí no me afecta eso piensen que algo
como esto se basa fundamentalmente en
que lo femenino en general es débil y
estúpido
y
en 1954 los personajes de marilyn la
convirtieron en lo que representaba a
ser sexy en eeuu rubia de buen cuerpo y
tonta muy a su pesar este bueno en los
estudios le empezaron a dar papeles que
explotaron esta imagen por supuesto era
su estrella más rentable y marilyn dijo
de que él no quiero hacer eso hizo una
aparecer de las cosas más audaces que
una actriz de ese tamaño y en ese
momento pudo haber hecho rechazó los
papeles se mudó a nueva york se metió en
una escuela de actuación y eventualmente
es hizo su propia casa productora para
ella poderse dar las oportunidades de
demostrar que era no sólo buena actriz
sino de que era mucho más que sólo una
rubia tonta
cuando conocí youtube en el 2010 no era
una plataforma para hacerse famoso es
más creo que entonces el más famoso era
werevertumorro con cien mil suscriptores
que no me la creo que ahorita hay niños
que hacen eso con la mano a la cintura
en una semana
pero bueno eso más bien una plataforma
para para demostrar un mensaje bajo tus
propios términos en este momento empecé
a pensar que tal vez no era yo el que no
encajaba en los medios sino que los
medios no eran los que no funcionaban
para mí empecé a pensar que tal vez si
la gente fuera o sean viera que debajo
de todo esto soy una persona normal
estarían más receptivos a un personaje
como yo y también pensé que si tal vez
yo a los 16 años hubiera tenido una
imagen más positiva de lo que me podía
convertir pues no me hubiera sentido tan
solo ni tan inadaptado claro que yo
tenía que ser coherente y yo david no
represento a toda una comunidad
necesitaba un equipo en la primera
persona que pensé fue en luís rivas que
para ir a servicio portillo que es un
muchacho veracruzano muy guapo y que en
ese entonces trabajaba en televisión de
hecho en un programa que se llama guau
que hasta un tengo entendido era lo
único que era abiertamente gay en la
televisión nacional
y en mi cuna y una niña trans de sinaloa
que a pesar de ser un este un estado tan
machista tenía una genuina edad que
nunca en mi vida había visto y mire que
conocí a mucha gente tuve la fortuna de
que creyeran en esta lo que era que les
propuse y así nacieron los jonas blogs
y luego
gracias a rock jacks bueno antes de
lanzar el proyecto la verdad no les voy
a mentir yo estaba aterrorizado o sea no
tenía con qué compararlo no sabía cómo
la gente lo iba a recibir entonces se me
ocurrió preguntarle a toda la gente que
yo conocía como de oye qué opinas este
dame un consejo no sé qué ya pues todo
mundo me dio su feedback y un día mi
jefe me dio su respuesta en el siguiente
correo que se les huele porque no me lo
aprendí en cuanto a tu blog preferiría
que tampoco firmar las cosas hay que
cuidar mucho las acreditaciones por
ejemplo si vamos a un evento privado la
marca no busca salir en un canal de
youtube con alguien que salen wow y con
una vestida lo cual se me hace muy
divertido pero no es el target
porque si a los 16 años yo me había
prometido que nunca iba a salir del
closet estaba ahorita en previó un
proyecto que no sólo dependía de eso
sino de vivirlo públicamente porque con
este correo me di cuenta que era
necesario
a inicios del siglo 20 cuando apareció
el cine la gente de teatro lo veía como
un entretenimiento basura como algo
casero y pasajero para las masas que
nunca iba a tener la importancia que el
teatro representaba en ese momento
y cuando apareció youtube la televisión
lo veía como un entretenimiento basura
algo que nunca iba a tener la
importancia que la televisión tenía en
ese momento pensar que estamos a inicios
del siglo 21 me hace me hace sentir que
la temporalidad es casi poética creo que
la historia a veces sí es cíclica cuando
la industria de youtube explotó todos
pasamos de ser amateurs que subían
vídeos desde su cuarto a figuras de
relevancia mediática y si bien por fin
me gustó tener una voz algo que no me
gustó fue que me osea yo al estar fuera
del closet y otros compañeros que
también lo estaban nos convirtieron en
youtube gay
y a mí esta etiqueta me molesta mucho
porque cuando le ponen algo la etiqueta
de gay no necesariamente tiene que ver
con la orientación sexual especialmente
en un proyecto como que a veces es como
si fuera la versión chafa de algo
legítimo y para mí youtube gay suena
hasta la fecha suena tan ridículo como
decir cine gay o música gay
como si los gays por ser gays sólo
habláramos de cosas que es relevante
para la gente gay
y otra cosa que también me sorprendió
fue que empecé a conocer a otros
creadores de contenido y me di cuenta
que a pesar de que pertenecían a la
comunidad del gbc muchos de ellos
estaban en el closet y yo decía porque
si estamos en una industria en la que no
dependemos vídeo y directivos ni de
productores ni de nadie que nos diga
cómo hacer las cosas estamos cometiendo
un acto tan grande de autocensura o sea
yo la verdad que no lo entendía cuando
el youtuber 'juan pablo jaramillo salió
del closet mencionó algo en su vídeo que
me llamó mucho la atención dijo a mí me
daba miedo salir del closet por los como
porque mira cerrar contratos con marcas
inmediatamente pensé en un compañero al
que de hecho si le cancelaron un
contrato por hacer un vídeo con nosotros
entonces en ese sentido juan pabló tenía
razón la etiqueta de guía y en la frente
sí mermaría su mensaje pero a mí se me
ocurrió pensar en ellen degeneres esta
comediante que cuando salió del closet
en los 90s fue revolucionario 20 años
después y en una industria donde nos
están dando las llaves del juego la idea
de tener un público y después salir del
closet
me parecía socialmente irresponsable
para mí de repente este todo este viaje
no me di cuenta que no era acerca de
fama se convirtió para mí en importante
demostrar que uno podía ser conocido
relevante e incluso querido sin importar
las diferencias es más con la
importancia de las diferencias
y es y de repente les dijimos ok
necesitamos hacer algo porque nuestro
público mayormente los que nos acogieron
primero fue la comunidad el gmt
obviamente y yo estoy muy agradecido por
eso pero necesitábamos como ampliar un
poco nuestro público entonces en en esa
época youtube y los medios tradicionales
eran como dos mundos paralelos que
parecían estar peleados uno con el otro
entonces era muy raro ver a un que un
personaje de uno saltará al otro
entonces nos ocurrió pensar tal vez si
consiguiéramos por ejemplo un artículo
en una revista teen podríamos darnos a
conocer entre un público más diverso
esto sonaba como un súper buen plan en
teoría pero nos batearon nos explicaron
lo difícil que sería tener para explicar
para los papás de los lectores tan
jóvenes el porque tenían personajes que
dicen sus páginas así que va digamos a
ok así que si los medios tradicionales
ni las marcas y muchos youtubers que
quisieran colaborar con nosotros de
nuestro lado teníamos que hacer algo
para hacer ruido entre una audiencia más
avid más diversa y rápido y se me
ocurrió algo que
y este que youtube estaba ignorando en
este momento y que yo desde los 14 años
conocía muy bien las celebridades
[Música]
y nos acercamos a distintas personas y
les empezamos a proponer cómo podíamos
intercambiar un poco de su tiempo a
cambio de que ellos presentaran algún
proyecto que tuvieran en puerta y
funcionó conocimos a muchas personas muy
divertidas e interesantes e incluso
comprobé algo que desde hace años ya
sospechaba y esque janguear con paris
hilton si es más divertido que la clase
de mis esperancita
ves dondequiera que esté
creo que una de las razones por la por
la que marilyn ha hecho eco hasta
nuestros días tiene mucho que ver con la
manera en la que murió pero también
tiene mucho que ver con la manera en la
que vivió y yo de ella aprendí la
importancia de construir té y ser la
persona que quiere ser aprendí la
importancia de ser uno mismo
que aunque suena cliché es lo más
difícil que uno puede hacer en un mundo
donde te dicen que lo seas pero cuando
lo eres inmediatamente te señalan y te
censuran
ser uno mismo es una de las cosas más
difíciles que uno puede ser yo lo sé día
con día acaba que una marca no quiere
trabajar conmigo cada que no me quieren
dar un papel cada que un hitler me
comentas de que [ __ ] gotita
pero cuando se ponen difíciles las cosas
trato de pensar en una frase de una de
mis películas favoritas de almodóvar
todo sobre mi madre y es una frase que
dice uno es más auténtico cuanto más se
parece a lo que siempre ha soñado de sí
mismo gracias
[Aplausos]